hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
for my bonus arrow video I'm gonna do a
breakdown of the Justice League movie
that they just announced with Zack
Snyder so we'll start with all the
confirmed stuff first and then I'll talk
about all the characters I think they
should include as well as the stories
they'll do I know a lot of you guys have
been asking me - about you know Stephen
Amell and Grant Gustin being in it so
I'll talk about that as well if you're
finding me for the first time I'm just
doing bonus arrow videos counting down
to the finale that's episode 23 that's
in two weeks there's only two more
episodes after tonight so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and leave me
suggestions for future bonus videos
whenever arrow goes off the air I'll
still keep doing you know bonus videos
for that but they'll be you know DC
stuff too like Justice League and other
movies so first things first let's start
with the confirmed news what they just
announced the other day Warner Brothers
confirmed that Zack Snyder will direct
Justice League and that it will shoot
back-to-back with Superman vs Batman so
it is possible if they get the script
done quickly enough they could hit a
2017 release date but planned for spring
2018 they haven't announced officially
who's writing it but I would assume that
several people are going to be involved
I know a lot of people are wondering
about Christopher Nolan but he's kind of
moved on from DC movies he wasn't even
really involved at all with Superman vs
Batman that script was written by David
s Goyer and Zack Snyder they'll
definitely be part of the Justice League
writing team but because casting Ben
Affleck was such a huge deal I would not
be surprised at all if he has something
in his contract that gives him script
approval or a chance to take a pass at
the script Christopher Nolan could
always be helicoptered in for any
emergencies to Justice League is a huge
risk for them so they'll spare no
expense in making sure it makes billions
of dollars so now let's talk about the
cast you know obviously the Holy Trinity
is going to be back but let's talk about
all the new characters that they've
recently announced these are basically
all the new characters that they
announced for Superman versus Batman
because most of them will probably be
returning including Jesse Eisenberg as
Lex Luthor Jeremy Irons as Alfred and
Rey Fisher is cyborg but what about all
the other Justice League members I mean
there's a huge roster and you have
people like Stephen Amell and Grant
Gustin who are killing it on TV right
now here's the reality because Zack
Snyder is doing Justice League it
implies that the tone of the movie will
be consistent with his Man of Steel
movies so the story will flow with the
energy and visually the world will look
the same there will just be more
characters in a more complex story so
here's what we have to talk about the
filming schedule for Justice League
because it overlaps with where a lot of
these TV shows are being shot Superman
versus Batman started filming in
February and that will take about six
months to finish so if Justice League is
gonna film back-to-back it means they'll
start this fall right in the middle of
arrow season 3 and flash season 1 which
is bad news for anyone that wants to see
Stephen Amell and Grant Gustin in the
movie but that does not mean that they
won't be in it at all it just means
there's zero chance they're gonna have a
major role they could always have just
like a really quick two second cameo in
plain clothes you know not as their
comic book characters but just as like
Oliver Queen and Barry Allen
so Warner Brothers will never say you
know no they're never gonna be in the
movie they just want to leave the chance
you know in speculation open just
because they want fans to stay excited
about it but based on those shooting
schedules plan for them to not be in it
because Stephen Amell often talks about
basically working almost 24 hours a day
7 days a week whenever arrow shooting
but what about all the other billions of
Justice League characters that there are
the roster is huge so here are my top 5
characters that I think they should
include in it at least in cameos if not
as full-on characters number 5
Zatanna they have an established magic
in the main steel universe so they'd
have to bend some of the logic on our
powers but they have to include some
more girl power on the team you know a
lot of people got really upset with JJ
Abrams and Disney whenever it seemed
like the new Star Wars trilogy was just
going to be another boys club number for
Aquaman
again they'd have to be a little timely
why me with his backstory powers how
could Superman have all these amazing
senses and not know about a race of
highly advanced Atlanteans living in the
ocean but Aquaman could always cameo as
a normal person
as Arthur not in costume like say Oliver
Queen getting a cameo but not the arrow
number 3 Shazam again another magic user
so they'd have to establish a credible
explanation first powers or he could
just be Billy Batson in the movie right
now though Dwayne Johnson is developing
a project with DC and Warner Brothers
and it's supposed to be
Shazam that's what the rumors are saying
number 2 Supergirl
I think it would be really fun to see a
Keira cameo not a full-on suit wearing
Supergirl
it's just another interesting way of
deepening the new Man of Steel mythology
that they created with that first Man of
Steel movie and my number one new
character that I think they should
include Martian Manhunter
we're gonna need Oreos lots and lots of
Oreos even if they don't want to include
him officially just because it'd be too
weird with the characters they already
have it would be so awesome if they just
added some Easter eggs in the form of
like cookie trucks or cookie ads in
reality though they probably already
have most of the Justice League casts
that they're going to use in the movie
if you look at Superman versus Batman on
paper essentially it looks a lot like
world's finest so the story from that
will lead directly into Justice League
we don't know a lot about the story for
Superman versus Batman or Justice League
obviously but the rumors right now are
that you know Batman is basically going
to hate the crap out of Superman for
most of Superman versus Batman no idea
how Wonder Woman is going to enter the
story but Justice League will not form
until all the characters unite in common
cause against Lex Luthor and whatever
villains they end up throwing in so now
it's your turn let me know which
characters do you want to see them add
for the Justice League movie and what
kind of stories do you think they should
do so be sure to subscribe to get all my
arrow bonus videos there's only two more
weeks be sure to leave me suggestions
for what you want those to be about too
so my review tonight will post right up
to the episode airs you can actually
click here to get that I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post it and you
can click here to get the Q&A video for
Thursday thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you